bonsoir et bienvenue dans cette nouvelle
édition du 7 8 sport l'émission
consacrée à l'actualité sportive dans le
département tout de suite on passe au
sommaire cyclisme sur piste le vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines
organise son premier grand prix ce
vendredi 70 pis là ont participé à ce
rendez-vous les détails dans cette
édition
tennis de table club d'élan pour
cinquième du championnat de pro a
féminine a décidé d'arrêter le haut
niveau pour nous expliquer cette
décision nous recevrons sur ce plateau
le président du club jean manuel morais
le coach franck saulnier dans quelques
instants
basketball les cadets de l'élan et vine
basket sont devenus champions de france
en battant en finale monaco 93 à 86 mené
de 24 points au bout de 15 minutes ils
ont arraché la victoire quand nous
reviendrons sur cet incroyable exploit
dans ce magazine
et puis enfin l'émission comme tous les
ans depuis nous regardons sur tous les
résultats sportifs du week-end dans le
département nous parlerons du défi
nature organisée sur l'île de loisirs de
saint quentin en yvelines et de la
montée en nationale une de
montigny-le-bretonneux le premier grand
prix du vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines était
programmée ce vendredi 70 cyclistes de
haut niveau ont participé à cette
compétition dans les têtes d'affiché
spectateurs ont pu voir en action sandie
clair ou encore le pistard de l'équipe
de france ce kevin sireau
les images sont signés elodie moines
mission réussie les lots de 50 ans yves
hinant risée son grand prix vendredi
dernier une compétition qui a réuni plus
de 70 cyclistes sur la piste et près de
200 spectateurs dans les gradins
l'idée c'était drôle de noceurs créés
sur ce qui s'était passé avec les
mondiaux
en plus de ça on vous dit est de créer
l'événement c'est que l'année prochaine
il soit toujours là pour bénéficier
d'une classe supérieure de manière à
qualifier plus facilement des français
pour les autres compétitions
internationales comme les coupes du
monde ce grand prix du vélodrome a
surtout été créé pour permettre aux
pistards français d'emmagasiner de
l'expérience et de se perfectionner en
vue des prochaines échéances nationales
et internationales sur piste commence à
lancer un peu les compétitions en france
on en avait pas jusqu'à vraiment navet
mais fallait quand même en avoir une sur
cette belle piste qu'on a au centre
national mais pour nous c'est bon ça
permet de nous juger sur le début de
saison parce que vous savez la première
course pour ça la plupart d'entre nous
et puis voilà ça permet
engager la compétition
devant de la saison
cette saison olympique a fait du bien
plusieurs délégations étrangères ont
fait le déplacement pour cette grande
première des portugais des suisses mais
également des belges se sont affrontés
sur la piste du vélodrome
le niveau est bon à la qualité et le
nombre peut-être pas tout à fait mais
c'est un bon niveau donc pour nous ça
vaut la peine a certainement d'avoir
fait le déplacement pour pour continuer
à progresser et à apprendre
il serait bon qu'il y aurait encore
d'autres initiatives pareilles à
l'étranger par exemple dans d'autres
pays encore du côté des résultats la
france a brillé sur ce grand prix kévin
sireau s'est imposé sur l'épreuve de
vitesse ont deux manches face au
champion de france quentin lafargue chez
les femmes virginie cueff a battu olivia
montauban
enfin dans l'épreuve du kilomètre la
victoire est revenue à benjamin et de
l'ain qui a bouclé la distance en une
minute 3 secondes et 124 millièmes la 8e
édition du défi nature était programmé
ce week-end sur l'île des loisirs de
saint quentin en yvelines
les jeunes éléments jeunes ont pu tester
le canoë l'escaladé le golf encore le
vélo
le montage est signée roma respini le
défi nature souffler sa huitième bougie
ce week-end les participants ont pu
tester cette occasion sur l'île de
loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines une
dizaine d'activités gratuitement au
programme de cette 8ème édition du
cadeau et de l' escalade ou encore du
golfe
la vocation c'est de permettre à la
population locale en fait de venir
découvrir aussi les activités qui sont
proposées sur notre territoire et c'est
une occasion particulière de pouvoir
venir s'essayer gratuitement ces
disciplines et puis pourquoi pas après
pratiquer l'une d'entre elles
régulièrement
cette année l'accent a été mis sur le
vélo en référence aux championnats du
monde de cyclisme sur piste organisée en
février dernier à saint quentin en
yvelines pour faire découvrir ce sport
des parcours ont été mis en place et un
parcours pour d'initiation on va dire
donc c'est juste une petite montée un
petit parcours donc très court pour ceux
qui ne maîtrisent pas et puis à prendre
un par contre un peu plus long veillez
virage beaucoup plus serré
but c'est de ne pas mettre le plus en
sommes bien sûr j'ai fait un parcours
bleu et c'est quoi le parcours bleu
c'est en fait on doit remonter la pente
après on tournait à prendre part qu on
doit tourner on sort en mission en plus
dur en fait le défi nature à attirer
plus de 800 personnes sur l'intégralité
du week end l'événement soit reconduit
pour une neuvième édition le club de
tennis de table d'elancourt a terminé à
une belle 5e place dès sa première
saison en pro a
mais le club ne poursuivra pas
l'aventuré en proa suite à des raisons
économiques pour faire le point sur la
situation nous recevons sur ce bateau le
président jean manuel mort et le coach
de la section féminine franck le saunier
bonsoir bonsoir
j'imagine fonctionne et qu'il ya eu
beaucoup d'émotions sur dani match que
vous avoir remporté contre 51 4 à 2
c'était le dernier match d'un projet
d'une aventure ah oui oui bah une belle
aventure quand même ce que ça dure
depuis sept ans donc oui à saint quentin
laon nous ce qu'on a raté ça que ça se
passe pas à domicile
bon là su très vite avec le calendrier
en début de saison mais oui oui sur la
fin du dernier match c'était déjà
c'était un très bon match donc ça
c'était plutôt sympa aussi avec beaucoup
de monde puisque saint quentin le tennis
de table est vraiment très très bien
suivi un bon public et
donc oui c'était alors on était très
content mais un peu peu triste aussi
quand même et pourquoi avoir décidé
d'arrêter cette section élite
jean-manuel mort pour des raisons
économiques bien évidemment pas ça coûte
trop cher avoir une sexualité c'est un
sport professionnel c'est une équipe
avec beaucoup de déplacements et nous
avons en france un tennis de table de
très haut niveau avec
en féminines des joueuses sous les soul
et un mondial donc ça veut dire des
joueuses qui sont chères qu'est-ce que
vous avez été assez soutenue par par les
politiques dans cette démarche de haut
niveau on ne l'est jamais assez soutenu
locale qui gagne les moyens ça ça de
quoi oui quand on se compare aux autres
clubs de pro on est largement sous
subventionné puisqu'on est quand même un
sport sont subventions voilà la mairie
d'elancourt où la communauté d'agglo ont
fait tout ce qui était dans leurs moyens
après si on peut pas compter ni sur au
conseil général mission conseil régional
ça fait la différence avec les autres
clubs vous m'aviez dit quand je vous
avais rencontré il ya quelques semaines
que metz par exemple avait un budget au
moins 5 à 6 fois supérieure comment
expliquer justement cette différence
entre présente mais celle en cours en
finale et je vous dis essentiellement
sur des subventions du conseil général
et puis après sur une mobilisation plus
forte certainement du tissu
d'entreprises les en province il est un
petit peu plus aisés ou en tout cas
moins difficile d'avoir des accords de
sponsoring intéressant et la communauté
d'agglomération verser une subvention
pour l'année prochaine qui a été
augmentée
ça suffira pas ça suffira pas
oui et non c'est surtout que suite aux
aléas politiques puisque vous savez que
l'élection à montigny a été invalidée ça
reporte les votes des budgets sarr potes
les versements des aides
donc nous sommes dans une situation de
trésorerie qui ne permet pas d'attendre
six mois un an tout le monde tout le
monde repousse un petit peu dans le
champ du voisin et nous sommes les
derniers donc on nous en pâtissons
fonctionner l'objectif c'était de faire
de d'elancourt la meilleure équipe de
tennis de table de france peut-être
pendant les deux prochaines années
finalement vous finissez cinquièmes des
voix première saison en proie l'objectif
était remplie malgré tout oui
complètement sportivement mais toute
façon au sein du bureau du club
tout le monde est d'accord là dessus
c'est que sportivement ça a été une
véritable réussite d'ailleurs au début
de saison personne ne s'attendait à ce
qu'on termine à cette place là on
termine sur une place en plus
qualificative à une coupe d'europe donc
ce qui est quand même assez incroyable
avec quasiment je crois un des deux plus
petit budget du championnat vous avez
super surperformer oui oui ça on a on à
comprendre
après le côté économique on
on va laisser un petit peu côté là mais
c'est vrai que sur la table on a eu une
équipe qui s'est très très bien défendu
et qui a fait une deuxième phase de
championnat au delà de nos espérances
donc c'était vraiment c'était on
assistait déjà des très beaux matchs
avec un très haut niveau puisque en
france comme l'a dit jean emmanuel
celoni c'est le championnat le plus fort
avec l'allemagne et qui est apparemment
avec les féminines est plus fort que
même que l'allemagne mais oui on a eu
une équipe avec des d origine un peu
différentes et avec des caractères aussi
différentes mais la mayonnaise a bien
pris et ça a donné quelque chose de très
sympa ouais bah l'équipe qui est resté
concentré jusqu'au bout alors ça c'est
quand même assez extraordinaire parce
que on avait quand même un petit peu
fait sentir aussi que ça va être
compliqué de continuer d' aventure un
peu avant la fin du championnat pour
éviter de de les mettre un peu dans
l'embarras pour la suite des choses et
mais c'était assez surprenant parce que
les filles sont restés très concentrés
jusqu'au bout avec un état d'esprit vont
quasiment irréprochable quoi c'est
justement l'une des conséquences donc de
cette rétrogradation c'est les filles
audrey zarif par exemple il ya quelques
jours le trouvais toujours pas de club
elle était justement au micro de tv fil
78 j'ai demandé mais il y en a plusieurs
qui veulent pas parce que c'est déjà
recruté j'ai demandé à schiltigheim en
alsace on attend parce qu'on sait pas
s'ils vont monter en pro b
ça va être la pro b mois souvent ça va
être la proie donc
voir franck saunière assuré nous des
tarifs va trouver un club où en tout cas
elle est en train de dessiner un nouveau
classement lui souhaite vraiment je lui
souhaite vraiment mais c'est compliqué
enfin compte faut savoir qu'en france
les contrats de deux joueuses de ce
niveau là se discute entre janvier et
février donc les quasiment à mi mars les
joueurs savent à peu près où elles vont
jouer déjà la saison prochaine alors que
le championnat n'est pas terminé
c'est un peu un peu particulier au
tennis de table mais c'est comme ça
audrey est un peu dans une impasse
d'ailleurs qu'elle a là des contacts
mais y'a rien qui a été finalisé c'est
quand même dommage pour elle parce que
ça reste quand même une des meilleures
juniors françaises encore l'année
prochaine
elle parla aux championnats d'europe là
cet été j'espère qu'elle va trouver
quelque chose avec un projet intéressant
surtout voilà c'est surtout ça qui va
être important pour elle maintenant
c'est de trouver une équipe qui va
pouvoir la soutenir et dans son projet
pour accéder au niveau j'aurai manuel
mort pour les autres joueuses vous à
l'e3 les solutions également aux
enseignants de club alors les joueuses
c'est pas forcément nous qui trouveront
des solutions pour elle même si on les
accompagne pour
pour eva pour yann et pour ben hiba oui
c'est fait donc reste
audrey et pénélope qui sont encore un
petit peu dans en recherche et quel sera
l'avenir du coup de dés l'encours du
tennis de table à elancourt alors que la
rose et la bombe avant d'être plutôt
vers vers la formation c'est ça oui on
va revenir à nos bases ce qui a toujours
fait la différence à elancourt il faut
voir que ces sept dernières années nous
avons élu évoluer au plus haut niveau en
pro mais c'est pas ça qui représentent
la majorité de
de nos pratiquants de nos adhérents il
ya une dynamique de club sur la
formation des plus jeunes se soient
garçon ou fille merci à vous d'être
passé sur ce plateau on continuera à
vous suivre les poils alain prochaine
malgré cette rétrogradation
coup de projecteur maintenant sur la
rencontre interécoles municipales
organisées à elancourt mercredi dernier
les enfants des écoles municipales
d'elancourt de coignières de mon team
autonome de voisins bretons ne se sont
affrontés au complexe sportif europe
la compétition était organisée donc au
complexe sportif europe où william elle
pour les images un parfum de jeux
olympiques régné au complexe sportif
europe d'elancourt les enfants de quoi
il hier de montigny le bretonneux de
voisins-le-bretonneux et des locaux ont
participé mercredi à la rencontre
interclubs municipal des sports
les ateliers étaient organisés pour
l'occasion cette affaire nous avons six
ateliers donc là nous sommes dans la
salle d'agrès on avait on la parcourt un
parcours gymniques sur les agrès de
gymnastique
nous avons un atelier de jeux d'adressé
et de précision dans la grande salle
dans le dojo nous avons un atelier j'ai
d'opposition dans la salle de danse un
atelier danse où il ya une petite
chorégraphie qui a appris aux enfants et
nous avons également deux ateliers à
l'extérieur un atelier hockey et un
atelier athlétisme au total 120 enfants
âgés de 6 à 11 ans ont participé à ces
épreuves aussi bien à nous
j'espère que je reviendrai plus souvent
ici parce que l'occasion de les voir ils
font des sports toute l'année serait que
ce genre de journée c'est très sympa
parce que ça permet de se rendre compte
de ce qu'ils ont fait toute l'année de
les voir profiter parce que là ils
s'éclatent franchement très intéressant
il
essayez un peu tous les sports il
rencontre d'autres établissements donc
voilà tout ça en s'amusant c'est une
bonne journée je pense les résultats ne
sont pas pris en compte dans cette
compétition amicale l'objectif est de
faire découvrir de nouveaux sports aux
enfants alors n'a pas du tout un
objectif compétitif le principe de
l'école des sports
d'une manière générale c'est d'être
pluridisciplinaire et non compétitif
c'est ce qui la distingue des clubs donc
l'esprit de compétition est juste là
pour motiver les enfants et créer une
dynamique mais à la fin il y à une
récompense qui sera la même fortement
logo une nouvelle édition inter écoles
municipales devraient être programmées
l'année prochaine les enfants des villes
de plaisir et de maurepas pourrait
rejoindre la compétition
incroyable dénouement pour les moins de
17 ans de l'élan yvin basket cette
équipe qui réunit les meilleurs jeunes
du club du chenil de versailles de
maurepas et de poissy s'est imposé en
finale du championnat de france contre
monaco sur le score de 93 à 86 nous
recevons sur ce plateau le coach de
cette équipe
gauthier duval le responsable technique
eric desnoues et le capitaine marius
chambre
bonsoir son petit du valais ce que vous
attendiez une victoire contre monaco une
des meilleures équipes de france
bon on était 60 au départ donc 70
équipes on a fini dans le dernier carré
on avait gagné la demi-finale avec 20
points d'avancé quand même et on savait
que ça allait être du 50-50 sur cette
finale
ce qui interpelle également c'est le
scénario du match vous étiez menés de 24
points au bout de 15 minutes de jeu 46 à
22 et finalement vous avez renversé la
vapeur
sincèrement à -24 points il est plus
grand monde qui croyait les joueurs les
coaches et encore et on a renversé avec
la vapeur en première mi temps on est
revenue à 10 points après nous aurons
mis à 15 points puis la mi temps est
arrivé et là on a on a dit aux joueurs
vraiment de tout donner pour la deuxième
mi-temps et marius c'est vraiment le
discours du coach à la mi-temps qui a
fait la différence
oui oui 2
si vous aviez il nous a dit que on avait
toutes les qualités pour revenir et que
chacun apportant sa compagne et sa
défense
on allait revenir et être est on à
revenir à égalité
paddy par panier défense après défense
pour gagner le match était très engagé
également c'était monaco est une équipe
très athlétique
vous avez rester à leur répondre sur ce
plan là oui oui c'est plutôt nos
spécialités ça c'est plutôt notre
spécialité on était très agressif n'a
défendu dur et on les a mis dans les
cordes et c'est surtout grâce à cette
agressivité qu'on a qu'on est repassé
devant et vous étiez du coup comment
psychologiquement quand vous étiez menés
de deux temps différence à la mi temps
c'est fini c'est plié où justement il
faut y aller vous savez on est et on
s'est détendu et lens était là qu'on
s'est dit que l'on devait revenir n'a
pas de perdre devant points en finale on
a fait une saison magnifique à dix neuf
victoires une défaite donc on voulait
revenir et on s'est tous mis à la
mi-temps on y croyait à la mi-temps ali
moteur on était quasiment persuadé qu'on
allait y arriver parce que c'était on
avait déjà fait un retour sur les cinq
dernières minutes avant la mi-temps et
on était quasiment certain de d'aller
jusqu'à la victoire
eric desnoues est ce que justement cette
victoire montre que cette équipe a du
caractère
c'est clair qu'elle a du caractère il
faut savoir qu'on est parti complètement
en outsider c'est une jeune équipe
l'élan yvin basket c'est une sociaux
n'est pas un club c'est une structure
qui regroupe trois clubs maurepas
l'entente le chesnay versailles est donc
le club de poissy et ça regroupe
finalement les meilleurs potentiels des
yvelines donc au final c'est une belle
victoire pour les yvelines et ça montre
qu'il n'y a pas que les clubs pros
finalement qui peuvent avoir des
résultats donc c'est tout à l'honneur je
dirais de ces structures l'honneur des
jeunes entre guillemets il faut donner
surtout un gros coup de chapeau aux
parents parce qu'ils s'investissent
beaucoup y avait des entraînements au
chesnay versailles avait des
entraînements donc à poissy faut faire
tous les déplacements
donc c'est non seulement une belle
aventure humaine une splendide victoire
pour le staff technique les joueurs mais
voilà c'est vraiment la réussite de
cette coopération entre tous les clubs
des yvelines puisqu'on est on est des
joueurs qui viennent à peu près 2
je crois de six ou sept clubs différents
total et cette réussite justement elle a
été travaillée à l'entraînement c'est
vraiment le travail à l'entraînement qui
a payé sur cette saison je pense qu'il a
tout il ya bien évidemment le
savoir-faire des coachs
il y avait quand même un coach et deux
assistants mais il ya surtout cette
unité au niveau de l'équipe parce que
sur le papier à la limite
individuellement on pouvait dire parce
qu'il ya aussi des gabarit athlétique
fin c'est un championnat qui est très
très physique et je dirais que par
rapport à ça c'est surtout l'unité de
l'éthique et l'esprit d'équipé qui a
fait que qui a fait que ça a fonctionné
au final ce folie jusqu'où cette équipe
est assez mature justement pour
encaisser la la douleur on va dire la
douleur la souffrance d'un entraînement
d'une saison quand même qui est assez
longue
alors pour la plupart de ses joueurs il
était avec des fois habitué à deux
entraînements par semaine mais ils sont
entraînés trois fois donc au départ la
charge de travail est certes difficile
mais je dirais que c'est comme tout on
s'habitue et puis mon les coaches ont
bien évidement de l'expérience pour
arriver à un moment donné à gérer les
périodes de fatigue
il ya un stage donc de ressources qui
s'est fait donc en belgique et qui a
permis de bien aborder la deuxième phase
en tout cas de façon sereine et vous
avez en tout cas les moyens pour pour
réussir de belles saisons les longs et
jean baskets c'est une structure entre
guillemets c'est un vrai parcours
d'excellence pour les jeunes
on a dû 13 jusqu'à finalement seniors
donc avec du championnat de france donc
son petit à petit je dirais que on
construit on progresse et on espère
perdurer puisque on a quand même la
chance d'avoir trois clubs solides
derrière au niveau de la structure du
coup vous avez les moyens financiers
pour atteindre cet objectif dès lors
demandé un titre de champion de france
on essaye de les avoir entre guillemets
c'est pareil c'est pas évident parce que
forcément chaque club participe
financièrement mais on espère y arriver
bien évidemment gauthier duval cet
objectif de première place vous l'avait
annoncé dès le début si la saison non
non vous l'annoncer lors non non non non
non nous laisse aller en tout cas pas
vraiment un annonce avait vraiment pas
là où on allait des joueurs qui venaient
de département
deux régions peu de joueurs avaient joué
au niveau championnat de france mais on
avait pris les 20 pris les meilleurs
joueurs de chaque club était sont venus
chez nous chez nous dans les landes jean
baskets et grâce à ça et grâce au
travail parce que au début de l'année on
n'était vraiment pas ce niveau là on a
vraiment progressé toute l'année et moi
pour le résultat qu'on connaît et
comment créer une cohésion justement
entre tous ces joueurs qui viennent de
finalement de plusieurs villes où il ya
plusieurs choses
un capitaine très investis qu'elle suit
vraiment soudé l'équipe deux assistants
qui ont donné vraiment beaucoup beaucoup
de leur temps et un stage en belgique
pendant une semaine où ils sont partis
tous ensemble et qui nous a vraiment
aidés qui a vraiment soudé l'équipe et à
partir de là on était imbattable on a
remonté tous nos matches tous les scores
et ça a été vraiment exceptionnel à
partir de là l'ambiance justement au
sein du groupe allait aller comment
aller tout c'est une bande de potes
parce qu'on se connaissait en sélection
les essais chaque fois on mettait en
conduire en sélection yvelines tous
ensemble donc on était tous heureux de
se retrouver dans cette équipe on a
envie de hackers deux dernières années
deux cadets de pouvoir faire quelque
chose de grand de marquer l'histoire du
club parce que je crois que c'est le
premier titre national pour le club de
versailles et le de poissy et maurepas
donc c'était important pour nous et
comme on est tous amis dans la vie alors
on voulait être champion de france
regardez ça gravé à jamais le biais du
valais ce que cette génération est une
génération dorée est ce qu'ils peuvent
aller encore plus loin
malheureusement vous soyez des
catégories c'est à dire qu' il dise est
s'arrête pour eux je la moitié de
l'équipe passe dans la catégorie
supérieure
donc certains vont jouer en seniors
versailles
enfin versailles l'élan et d'une basket
propose pour ces jeunes une suite pour
leur parcours d'excellence
donc c'est une nouvelle génération qui
arrive et qui va essayer de faire aussi
bien que la génération précédente mais
c'était quand même une très belle
génération et vous y croyez pour l'année
prochaine ah j'y crois j'y crois
absolument mieux et on a gardé la moitié
de l'équipe
et puis avec la renommée le titre
beaucoup de joueurs ont envie de faire
partie de l'équipe maintenant donc on
est attractif merci à tous les trois
lettres passé sur ce plateau bon courage
pour la saison prochaine on passe
maintenant aux autres résultats du
week-end
on commence cette page résultat à part
du football en deuxième division de
district magny les hameaux n'a
finalement pas joué ce week-end son
adversaire à bailly noisy a déclaré
forfait avant la rencontre conséquence
lémanique war remporte la partie sur
tapis vert avec un score de 5 buts à 0
au classement lézignan montain finissent
troisièmes après avoir été en tête
pendant les trois quarts du championnat
farid gagner le coach de manille 78
était au micro de william l
il ya quand même le gros regret de ne
pas monter le globalement la saison a
été très bonne le groupe a fortement
progressé on a fait une très bonne
saison la montée qu'on avait largement
le niveau pour aller au dessus
malheureusement
depuis la défaite du chéné ça
cette a fortement ralenti puis manque de
sérieux de quelques joueurs aux
entraînements on l'a vite ressenti sur
le terrain toujours en foot ball trap à
jouer ce week-end l'ultime journée du
championnat de promotion d'honneur les
trappistes ont conclu leur saison par
une belle victoire à l'extérieur sur le
terrain de pontoise yens score final 3 2
pour les saint quentinois à la limite de
la relégation au mois de février trappe
s'est bien repris pour terminer la
saison à la quatrième place du
classement
il y avait également du tir à l'arc ce
week-end la compagnie d'arc des encours
organisé samedi dimanche la dernière
étape de la division régionale en équipe
et qu'elles sont meilleurs archers
franciliens étaient présents pour ce
grand rendez vous on les coupe philippe
roche le président de la compagnie d'arc
d'elancourt selon lui cette compétition
est très apprécié par les archers très
importante puisque c'est une compétition
par équipes donc c'est j'espère c'est 6
il arriva à bien à bien s'en sortir à
monter aller en national ou en dn1 donc
c'est important pour le niveau est bon
oui celle-là c'est l'excellence donc on
est quand même dans le haut sommet de
l'île de france un nom dans la catégorie
des rh classique hommes et l'encours a
terminé à la 6e place du général magny
les hameaux assure également son
maintien dans l'épreuve des airs
classiques dames et l'encours se hisse à
la 4e place du général
handball incroyable exploit défini de
montigny le bretonneux les joueuses de
philippe l'étrange philippe étrange
qualifiant barrage suite au retrait du
havre se sont imposés en match décisif
contre nîmes ce samedi à villefranche
sur saône près de lyon esi monteyne ont
dominé leurs adversaires sur le score de
30 à 26 grâce à des buts de carole
mittelheisser et à 6 buts d'amandine va
ses conséquences montigny-le-bretonneux
remontant nationale une dix ans après
être redescendu
l'objectif pour là saison prochaine
avait déjà été annoncé le maintien pour
cela le mercato risque d'être
mouvementée cet été du côté de montigny
en baisse bao'an baseball les cougars de
montier bretons ne se déplacer sur le
terrain de is in pour le compte de la 8e
journée du championnat de 2e division
comme au match aller les joueurs de
montigny-le-bretonneux aura apporté dans
leurs valises une défaite et une
victoire les y monte 1 se sont inclinés
dans leur premier match 5 heures ils se
sont ensuite largement imposés dans le
second la seconde partie sur le score de
18 à 10 au classement les cougars
pointent toujours à l'avant dernière
place du championnat avec sept défaites
en 13 matches disputés
on passe au badminton le club de
voisins-le-bretonneux a remporté la 36e
coupes divines jeunes grâce à ses très
bons résultats ce week-end au complexe
sportif des pyramides à voisin pendant
les principaux résultats on note la
belle victoire de dimitri brachet du bcv
contre françois jolivet duval de
carrières sur seine dans le tableau à
cadets quentin beau visage a remporté la
finale contre teddy et au lait de
gargenville en termine ce magazine par
deux dates le budo club d'elancourt
organise son passage de ceinture ce
vendredi de 19 heures à 22 heures au
complexe sportif europe
la compétition est ouverte au public au
total plus d'une cinquantaine de
karatékas s'en est attendu pour ce grand
rendez vous enfin une autre date à
cocher dans vos agendas pour les
amateurs de badminton au collège jean
françois champollion deux voisins
bretons nord organise pour ses classes
de 6e un tournoi interclasses de
badminton
la compétition est programmé au centre
sportif les pyramides à voisin retenu
c'est la fin de cette fuite sport merci
d'avoir suivi je vous retrouve lundi
prochain pour une émission spéciale golf
très belle soirée sur tv fil 78